Speaker 1: OK, real quick. I don't want to spend
a ton of time on this, but I want to just show you
that the Tucker Carlson Fox News program has
become a complete and totally open platform
for conspiracy theories at this point in time.
That's all it is. Yesterday, I showed you how
Tucker loves this. Ray Epps, the FBI did the
Trump riots conspiracy theory, and he used
Ted Cruz to push it. He then had on Glenn Beck,
who has COVID right now and allowed Glenn Beck to
push the Washington state COVID internment
camp conspiracy theory. If you haven't heard
about it, I'll tell you about it in a moment.
Speaker 2: The Great Reset is not a conspiracy
theory. It is something that the Davos people have
put together along with the World Economic Forum,
and it is running rampant through every western
capital and every western company country. It is.
I just I just read this tomorrow morning at
9:30. The Washington state COVID detainment
emergency. They are going to have
a state board of health discussing
from 9:30 to 3:30 tomorrow, allowing health
local health officers to use law enforcement
to force an emergency order in involuntarily
detaining a person or group of persons families
to be isolated in a quarantine facility following
the refusal to voluntarily comply with request
medical examinations testing. By the
Speaker 1: way, if you're not watching,
Tucker's doing the confused
face the entire time here, sling
Speaker 2: and vaccination. This is an internment
camp. Washington state has done it before.
They haven't obviously learned their
lesson from World War Two. This, again,
is all about total and complete control.
Speaker 1: Now, everything Glenn Beck is
saying is a lie. This has been widely debunked.
Let me tell you what's going on. No rights cream.
Washington won't forcibly quarantine those who
have COVID or are unvaccinated. The State Board
of Health has received thousands of emails about
an agenda item that will be discussed this week.
Claims are going around that Washington
politicians are trying to create laws that
would allow them to force unvaccinated people into
quarantine. The State Board of Health received
thousands of emails we set out to verify claims.
The question Does this proposal allow health
officials to use law enforcement to force an
emergency order to involuntarily detain a person
or group in a facility if they refuse to comply
with requests for medical treatment, testing,
treatment counseling or vaccination? The answer?
No. The state isn't trying to quarantine forcibly
those who have COVID or are unvaccinated. Just to
be really clear, our board meeting on Wednesday
is there are no conversations about
isolation and quarantine camps.
There are no rules existing or in the making
to create isolation and quarantine camps.
There are no rules and there is no process in
place to create a rule to involuntary quarantine,
voluntarily quarantine or isolate COVID 19
positive people, regardless of vaccination.
There are no laws and no plans to do it, period.
It's just bogus. It's this there's nothing there.
And Tucker Carlson's Fox News program, which is,
I think, at this point, the most widely listened
to right wing program. I mean, maybe Joe Rogan
is considered a right wing program now and has
a bigger audience, but it is one of the biggest
right wing programs. Every day, there's a new
conspiracy theory if you watch Tucker and you
accept the stuff on there. The feds did 911.
I'm sorry that the feds did the Trump riots,
not 911. Maybe they say the feds did 911,
too. I don't know the feds did. The Trump riots
is what I mean, and they're going to in turn,
there's going to be an internment camp for people
with COVID in Washington every day. It's a new
conspiracy theory, extraordinarily dangerous
stuff. And if you're just listening today,
we'll have these clips up on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.